[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANA: Welcome, everybody.
We are super excited to
have Barry Friedman here
to talk about his latest
book, Unwarranted, Policing
Without Permission.
Barry is a professor at the New
York University School of Law.
And he's spent the last 30
years writing and teaching
and litigating about issues
of constitutional law
and criminal procedure.
He is also the author of the
book The Will of the People.
And his writing has
appeared in New York
Times and Slate and Republic.
Also joining us
is Deborah Jones--
DEBORAH JACOBS: Jacobs.
ANA: Jacobs.
I'm so sorry, Jacobs--
who is the director of the
office of law enforcement
oversight here in King County.
She's got a long career
working in executive leadership
positions at the ACLU,
specializing in policing
procedures and practices.
BARRY FRIEDMAN: Thank you, Ana.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you all for coming.
I'm very, very happy to be here.
It's my first trip to Seattle,
and certainly to this campus.
So I'm going to start by telling
some stories about policing.
I could actually
start with the Dallas
shooting of Jordan Edwards,
which is kind of a tragedy.
Because I tell so many stories
about policing having gone off
the rails, I also always
stop at this point,
and say that I
spend a lot of time
now working with
policing agencies,
and with policing
officials trying
to fix some of the things
that have gone off the rails.
And there are a lot of
great people in policing
who want to get it right.
And it's important for us all
to be there in a helpful mode
to get that to happen.
So I'm going to tell
you some stories.
And I have a question for you,
because I'm a law professor.
And the question is, I want you
to think about these stories.
I want you to think
about these stories.
[LAUGHTER]
[LAUGHS] That was subtle.
I want you to think about--
[LAUGHTER]
I want you think
about these stories
and, try to think about, if you
can, what they have in common.
They're going to seem very,
very different to you.
So this is Freddy Martinez.
Freddy was physics trained.
He's works in the tech
industry in Chicago.
He's an activist.
This is a stingray.
I'm just curious, being here,
who knows what a stingray is?
Everybody knows what a
stingray-- or a lot of people.
So I'm going to tell the
few people who don't.
We'll clue them in.
So a stingray is a
cell tracking device.
The police use it to figure
out where a cell phone is,
or what cell phones
are in the area.
It has some incredibly
important uses for policing.
If you think about a kidnapping,
for example, and you've
a cell phone number, and
you want to figure out
where the person is--
very helpful.
It also, however,
can be used to record
the phone numbers of
everybody that's at a protest.
And that was Freddy's
interest, which was--
were the Chicago police
collecting at Black Lives,
for example, protests,
the cell phones of people?
And he was trying to think about
a way to engineer something
to defeat the stingrays.
And then somebody said
to him, why don't you
just file a Freedom of
Information Act request?
So he filed a Freedom of
Information Act request,
and he was stonewalled
for a very long time.
And so he hired--
or, he joined up with
this man, Matt Topic,
who is a lawyer in
Chicago who litigates
Freedom of Information request.
In fact, Matt was involved
in the release of the Laquan
McDonald video in Chicago.
And what they learned was
that the Chicago police
had, for many years,
been using stingrays.
And when they try to
dig deeper, and ask
a lot of questions about--
did you have court authority?
Had you vetted the
legality of this?
What were you doing
with the data?
Were you storing the data?
They got stonewalled again.
The city of Chicago
hired a firm,
and quickly spent a couple
hundred thousand dollars
on not answering any
of their questions.
But while that was
happening, and they
were getting kind
of non-responses,
people started to notice
around the country
that the same non-responses,
almost in identical language,
were appearing from police
departments in California
and in Georgia.
And eventually, people piece
together what was happening,
which is that the FBI
had gotten stingrays
into the hands of local
law enforcement agencies
with non-disclosure
agreements that
said that no matter what, they
couldn't reveal what technology
was being used.
So for years, law
enforcement agencies
had not been getting court
orders, or lying to judges
and getting court orders.
There was even a
clause that said
that if you were in
the middle of a trial
and you were about to say
what the technology was,
that you had to-- the prosecutor
had to dismiss the case.
And there are instances
where that happened.
And so that's one example of law
enforcement use of technology.
And we'll be back to that.
But here's a different story.
So this is Tamir Rice.
Tamir Rice, as I
think all of you know,
was playing with a toy gun
in a park in Cleveland,
and somebody called the
police and said that there was
a male with a gun in the park.
The police responded.
Dispatch never relayed
the information
that it might have
been a candidate,
it might have been a toy gun.
They came flying into
the park in a squad car--
a patrol car.
They stopped within
just feet of Tamir Rice.
And within seconds, an
officer had jumped out
and shot him twice, left
him on the ground bleeding.
They didn't have any
emergency care equipment it.
Took several minutes
for EMS to get there.
And as you all know, he died.
This is Charles and Etta Carter.
So Charles and Etta Carter
lived outside of Philadelphia.
Very humble jobs for many years.
They had one kid who got her
PhD in developmental psychology,
super proud of her.
She gets a new job in Florida
working in the school system.
She gets married, they buy a
new house, everything's new.
So they do what good
parents do, they
loaded up a van full of stuff
that the couple might need,
and they went down to Florida.
And they stayed for
a couple of months,
and then when they
were done, they
turned around and came back.
And on a really,
really hot July day,
they were stopped by the
Maryland State Patrol.
And all the Maryland
State Patrol
ever said was that
Charles had been
driving wobbly, or weaving.
They took them out of the car.
They put them up on an
embankment out of the van.
They started to take
everything out of the van.
They tore open bags
of laundry detergent,
breakfast cereal,
wedding invitations
from her daughter's wedding.
They tossed the wedding
dress out into the back.
Fortunately it had been wrapped
up and wasn't destroyed.
Took out lawn chairs,
took apart a refrigerator.
And all the while,
the Carters sat out
on this embankment in the heat.
They called a drug dog in.
The drug dog urinated
around their belongings.
And eventually, on
several occasions,
Etta Carter, who had
a bladder problem,
asked if she could use a Porta
Potti that they had in the van.
And the police said no.
They threatened to cuff
her if she got up again.
And so, on a day that
was her 40th anniversary,
she was forced to
sit on an embankment,
and urinated all over herself
while the officers looked
through her belongings.
They eventually let them
go with just a warning.
Never an apology of any sort.
They went to a rest stop
so she could clean up.
They went back to their
home in Philadelphia.
They had several sleepless
nights, didn't know what to do.
Eventually went to the
AAA looking for help.
The AAA sent them to
the ACLU of Maryland,
and there was a lawsuit filed.
It was eventually settled.
But the truly
remarkable thing was
that throughout the
entire litigation--
I'd read through
all the depositions,
nobody in the
Maryland State Patrol
ever thought that
anything had gone
wrong, that anything had ever
happened outside of procedure.
This is a slide just to
tell a story of a fellow who
was an Iraqi war vet who wakes
up in his apartment complex
in the suburbs here
in the United States.
And because he'd been
on many raids himself,
knew exactly what was happening
when he woke up to gun barrels
in his face.
He just had no idea why
any of it was happening.
It turned out that his
apartment was being--
undergoing some maintenance.
And so the department
development
had moved him into a
different department.
Some of the neighbors wondered
who was in that apartment.
They called the
police, and the police
responded with a SWAT raid.
He went down to the police
station the next day
and said, investigate,
call the apartment complex,
ask security who was
in that apartment.
And they said, we
don't investigate.
It kind of gets in the way
of our apprehending suspects.
This is just-- there are--
you're driving
under the influence,
cops want to give
you a breathalyzer.
But if it's drugs, the
breathalyzer won't work,
so it's become-- in fact, it's
becoming increasingly common.
I now get calls about this all
the time for-- particularly
in the Midwest, for police to
take folks to the hospital,
and have them forcibly
catheterized to get a urine
sample.
And including a case
where a fellow who
refused to sit still
for the catheter
was strapped to a gurney so that
they could insert the catheter.
And then just a quick reminder
that the NSA, as we all
learned from Edward Snowden,
was gathering the metadata
from all of our
telephone communications,
and also some of our
internet connections.
So the question I have that
I ask folks all the time is,
what do all these
seemingly different stories
have in common?
And we don't tend to think
of them as the same story
here in the United States.
We think about racial profiling,
we think about militarization,
we think about technology,
we think about use of force.
But my argument in the
book and in the work
I do with the policing
project that I've started
is that all of these stories
are united by a governance
failure, which requires
me to teach you
all of a minute of
constitutional law.
So when we think
about government
in the United States,
we think about
democratic accountability.
And I divide that up into
front end and back end
accountability.
And we know all about
front end accountability.
It's what you think of when
you think of democracy.
It's the idea that
we have rules,
that we put the rules in place
before officials act so we
know what they're going to do.
They're transparent.
We know what the rules are.
Indeed, we have a voice
in what those rules are.
There's always some
form of public input.
We try when we can to make
sure that the benefits outweigh
the costs.
Now we have back end
accountability, too,
which is to say, what
keeps that system running
and keeps it honest is that
we have courts that make sure
that everything that's supposed
to happen up front happens.
But it's the up
front part that we
think of as democratic
accountability,
but not in policing.
In policing, for bizarre
historical reasons,
we have almost no front
end accountability.
And all of our accountability
is on the back end.
It's things like inspectors
general, and civilian review
boards, and
court-appointed monitors,
and body cameras-- the sort
of stuff Deborah deals with,
and she'll talk a
little bit about.
Even body cameras, if you
stop and think about them,
are back end accountability.
All the stuff on the
back end is designed
to kick in when something
bad has happened to say,
can we figure out, was
somebody responsible?
Did something go wrong?
Is somebody to blame?
But what we don't
do around policing,
and this is the key thing that
I think has gone wrong is,
we don't involve the
public on the front end
to say, how do we
want to be policed?
What should the rules be
by which we're policed?
Should we all know what those
rules are, and have input
into them?
And the interesting
thing is, when
we do have that input
here in the United States,
when something
happens to cause us
to have that input for people
to get annoyed and speak up,
policy changes,
policing changes.
So I'm sure you
recognize this picture.
It's one of the
images from Ferguson.
After Ferguson, there's a big
debate about militarization.
That debate goes on
around the country.
And as befits a federal
system and a democracy,
different governments, different
states at the local level all
adopt different policies
about what should happen
with the military equipment.
Some decide to keep
it, some decide
to ship it back, some decide
that it's got to be online,
what equipment the government
has, so that folks can respond.
Some decide that the government
actually-- the police
have to come to the
city council, whatever,
and ask to get the permission.
But the policy changes.
Similarly with drones--
a lot of states
are now adopting
drone legislation
because people are focused
on the use of technology
around policing.
And even after the
Snowden revelations,
though it took Congress
a long period of time,
eventually what
happened is, there
was a big debate in Congress.
And we decided
that the government
shouldn't hold all that data.
And instead, it should be
held by private companies,
and should only be
available under court order.
So when we get the
public involved
in the front end, which
we don't do very often,
policing changes.
And the last kind
of big point I want
to make with some more images
is that this, ironically,
is good for the police.
So this is the sell to the
police, but it's important.
So there's been a lot of talk
about legitimacy of policing,
about trust in
policing agencies.
Well, it's not that
surprising that people
don't trust that there are
legitimacy issues when people
aren't engaged,
and when they don't
have a voice in what happens.
And so when there are
things like Stop and Frisk,
hundreds of thousands of
people a year in New York.
Or when there's
surveillance going
on that people don't
know about, then
in fact, when people learn,
or when people observe that,
there is a huge loss of
legitimacy and trust.
And that's painful
for policing agencies,
which need to understand--
and what progressive chiefs
understand is-- in fact,
we were working in Camden,
and there was a horrible
incident of an eight-year-old
girl that was shot and killed
in crossfire from a gang fight.
And somebody came forward,
a very wealthy person
elsewhere in New Jersey,
and offered up a big reward.
And nobody took the money
because what happens
is that, in these neighborhoods
when something goes wrong
and there's a shooting, nobody
cooperates with the police.
Nobody wants to
speak to the police.
People are threatened, they're
afraid to speak to the police.
And it's that lack of
legitimacy and trust
that keeps us from getting that
engagement with the public.
But here's kind of
an ironic story.
So Compton, part of
the sprawling place
that is Los Angeles, the
police department decides--
the L.A. sheriff's
department decides
that they're going to try out
some surveillance technology.
Big airplane in the sky,
remarkable resolution,
track crime that way.
Eventually, people find out.
It's in the newspapers.
People are extremely angry.
Remarkable statement by
the public information
officer for the L.A.
sheriff's department
says, look, when we
did this, we knew
that people kind of get
nervous about Big Brother, eye
in the sky.
So we thought we
just better kind of
keep it hush-hush
and not tell anybody.
Obviously people were
unhappy when they found out,
and that was the end of it.
But down the street
in Lancaster,
exact same technology, public
debate, they decided to use it.
And that happens time and again.
It's happened with drones.
It happened here in Seattle.
The police department
got some drones,
people learned about it,
were extremely unhappy.
They eventually had
to ship them to L.A.
Just a quiet the tempest.
So the idea I want
to leave you with
is that bringing front end
accountability to policing
is really important,
and makes a difference.
I started an organization called
The Policing Project to work
on those kinds of issues.
We do lots of different
things, but I just
want to mention a
couple that I thought
would be of particular
interest in this room.
So one thing that
we're doing is,
we're working all over the
country bringing community
voice to policing, trying out
different models of bringing
the police and the
communities together.
Decide how they
want to be policed,
often working with,
as you might guess,
extremely marginalized
neighborhoods,
communities of color.
The other thing
that we're doing,
which astonished
me when I started
to write the book-- so you
know, I didn't believe then,
and I very much
don't believe now
that we're safer because
of all this policing.
And I'm very curious about the
efficacy of policing practices,
so I said to my
research assistants,
go forth and get
me the literature
on cost-benefit
analysis of policing.
And they came back
with not very much.
And I said, no,
seriously, there must be.
We spend $100 billion a
year on public safety,
there must be studies.
Shockingly little cost-benefit
analysis done around policing.
But the one extraordinary
fact that I learned
was, in all of the little,
skimpy literature there was,
no attention paid whatsoever to
the social costs of policing.
So we might ask, look, we can
hire this many more officers,
we can do this many
more Stop and Frisks,
doesn't make us safer.
We have some estimates
to the cost of crime,
but no one ever
asks the question,
how do we monetize
the Stop and Frisk?
What is it-- what does it cost--
what's the value on being
stopped and frisked?
Or what's the value
on community trust
if it's lost when that happens?
And so around street policing
issues, around technology--
which is one of the really huge
issues around policing right
now, is the growth
of technology,
these are the kinds of
questions we need to answer.
That's all from me.
My friend Deborah's now going to
talk to you a little about what
she does here in Seattle.
DEBORAH JACOBS:
Thank you, Barry.
[APPLAUSE]
BARRY FRIEDMAN: Thank you.
DEBORAH JACOBS: Thank you so
much to Ana and [? Yves ?]
and David for hosting us.
It's really exciting to be
here, and see how you all live.
So I-- after working more
than 20 years for the ACLU,
I decided to settle into work,
specifically digging deep
on police practices.
And the reason I kind of
went to single-issue work
is, I see that as the
most critical area
of civil liberties.
It's the most direct, immediate,
dangerous confrontation
between a government
and its citizens.
And it's also the gateway
to mass incarceration.
And for me, for those
reasons, it really
rose up as someplace where
I'd like to dedicate my time.
So there aren't a ton of systems
to hold police accountable.
During the Obama
administration, we've
seen unprecedented
engagement with the DOJ.
I think he sent the DOJ out
more on police practices issues
than probably the last five
or six presidencies combined.
Those kind of-- it's
really a new thing.
But as we know, the
administration has changed.
And I think we have lots of
evidence to see the rollback.
So what's left for
accountability?
And you could also
really question
how the efficacy of DOJ
intervention, some success
stories, some rollbacks.
We'll see what happens in
Seattle, in particular.
But civilian oversight
is another way
of holding police accountable.
My office is one of 150
offices around the country that
engage in civilian-led
oversight efforts.
And by the way, I'm not in
love with saying civilian
because what's-- it's
versus military, right?
And I don't particularly want
our police to be militarized.
I also don't want to
use citizen because that
excludes a big chunk of our
population unintentionally,
I think.
But for now, it's
civilian oversight.
No two offices are the same.
You can't do apples
to apples comparisons.
And there's no one best
model, one best practice,
or way of doing the oversight.
What my office does is sort
of three key functions.
When the-- so one thing is,
we oversee the King County
sheriff's office.
That office covers all of
unincorporated King County,
and about a dozen jurisdictions
that contract for its services.
So that's Burine, Shoreline,
Beaux Arts, Maple Valley,
Woodinville, Muckleshoot
Reservation, and a bunch more
I can't pull off
the top of my head.
And so when you're in Burine,
you might see Burine police,
and then you'll see a little
King County sheriff under that.
So we have, compared
to the Seattle police,
a really diverse geographic
and otherwise area.
So you can't even compare
how Seattle does things
to how King County does things.
And that's something
to be mindful of.
So what the activities
my office do are,
one, when the sheriff's
office completes
an internal investigation,
we look at it
to see if it was
thorough and objective.
Is there bias in
the investigation?
Have they crossed their
T's and dotted their I's?
Two, we do systemic reviews,
use of force trends,
training issues.
One of the things that drives
me crazy about the training,
there's statewide, there's
a 24 hour annual training
requirement.
And at least the
King County sheriff's
office, that's all
done electronically.
None of it has to be
in-person training.
And I think there are huge
costs and issues around that.
Three, we do community outreach.
That's me right here,
right now, talking to you.
And for those of
you who think you're
covered by an area of the
King County sheriff's office,
I'd love to talk to you.
Because we have opportunities to
engage you, and I need to help,
people.
So identify yourself.
And then right now, we--
in November, 2015, the
voters of King County
voted to expand the authorities
of my office to include
individual investigations.
The King County council has just
passed an ordinance to do that.
And now that
ordinance is subject
to collective bargaining with
the 11 different unions that
represent the law enforcement
that make up the King County
sheriff's office.
So this will be a new
experience for me to see,
can we hold onto these
voter-endorsed rights?
It might interest you to know
that in Washington State,
a collective bargaining
agreement has
a higher legal authority
than an ordinance,
or even a vote of the people.
So I'm trying to live out some
of what Barry's talking about.
And he's correct in
saying a lot of what we
do are the back end solutions.
What can come on the front end?
So in our new
ordinance, one piece
is to have input on policies
before they're adopted.
Non-binding input, but
input nevertheless.
And that, as it happens, was
the piece of the ordinance
that they fought
hardest against.
And I don't--
I'm not sure what
that means, Barry.
You know, how much
is that related
to defensiveness of like,
no, we decide how we do it?
But the future is
what Barry describes.
It's-- when people talk
about community policing,
most of us get on our head,
that's a cop out of his car
in the community
to talk to people.
I think we need to take a more
aspirational viewpoint, which
is that community policing
is about the community,
through democratic processes,
setting the priorities of what
the police should be doing.
And Seattle has great
precedent for this.
When we-- God, how
long ago, 20 years ago,
passed a law that said marijuana
should be the lowest law
enforcement priority.
I don't think that's been done
here, or anywhere else since.
But it's the idea.
It's like, well, what do we
care most about in our community
that we want police to do?
And what we don't want them
to do, how are we going
to make up that difference?
So technology, I just want
to say a couple of things,
and then I'll not take
up any more of the time.
I know you want to ask
Barry a lot of questions.
But one thing that's a
big issue with police
is adopting technologies without
having thoughtful processes
for the policies behind them.
So I just found out that
King County sheriff's
has been using a
technology that there
was no real analysis of like,
what are the privacy rights?
How is this going to
be properly stored?
Or-- all those issues.
So I think for those of
you in the tech community,
if you're interested in policy
around privacy and technology,
there's a lot of room.
And I personally would love
to have your help, if that's
something, you're engaged with.
Another issue is better
technologies for police.
So one thing I said
at lunch, if you
want to become a
billionaire is, come up
with a great, non-lethal
way to stop people.
Tasers are sometimes
non-lethal, but if you
have an underlying
medical condition,
many hundreds of people now have
died from Taser applications.
And that's what they
rely on now, it's Tasers.
You have a gun on one
hip, a Taser on the other.
And unless they're
coming up fast at you,
you're going to take your
Taser and give it a try.
But it's not always reliable,
and they don't necessarily
trust it.
So they are, by the way--
they've already experimented
with web--
a net you can shoot.
But the newest trend is
sticky gum that you shoot.
And people-- it's
like a cartoon.
And go on YouTube, and look
for the demonstrations.
But they kind of stop people
from being able to move.
Those are not in use yet.
There's a lot of room for that.
And I think it's necessary.
And then finally,
one thing I notice
is that underlying systems
with which policing is managed
leave a lot of room
for improvement.
There's an industry
standard called IAPro--
Internal Affairs Pro, where all
the data is kept in most police
departments.
And there's so many
shortcomings to those programs.
And so this is an area where I
think there is tremendous need.
Again, I'm not a
big body camera fan.
I'm not against
technologies inherently.
I think they need to
work for the people.
Problem with body cams,
among other things,
is, they only face one way.
And I think where you have
something like a dash cam
where you're performing
in front of it--
although they can
also avoid those.
So a lot of issues there.
And I really appreciate
your interest in this.
My office is one of only
two independent oversight
offices in the state.
The other one's in Spokane.
I'd love for you to take
an interest in what we're
trying to do because it's
really about the future.
What kind of accountability
can we as citizens
assert in these dynamics?
And it's a work in progress
trying to get it right,
and lots of challenges.
But I can't think of a more
important field in which you
could share your talents.
So thank you.
And I'm going to help
moderate questions for Barry
because I love just being
up here and talking.
Come on, Barry.
We'll take questions.
[APPLAUSE]
So who has a juicy question?
Or even a just not juicy one?
AUDIENCE: Thanks a lot
for the great talk.
And I can't wait to check
out the rest of the book.
My question is
regarding firearms.
So this may be a
naive assertion,
but it seems like,
in the United States,
police have firearms
that are maybe
more dangerous than others.
And in fact, I think
in the UK, most police
aren't even equipped
with firearms.
So is that a unique
situation to the US?
And how do firearms play
in this whole thing?
BARRY FRIEDMAN: Yeah,
I mean, cultures
vary everywhere, right?
So in the UK, they largely
don't have firearms.
I just read a story
in the newspaper
that knifings are up in the UK.
So that's what gangs
use, their knives.
And apparently, somebody
tells me also, just kind of
fold people over and compress
them until they expire.
So we all come from
different cultures,
and things are done
differently in different ways.
We know that we come from a
very Rambo, Cal person culture,
and that involves
a lot of weaponry.
And it's a problem for the cops.
I mean, it's interesting.
If you talk to cops, they don't
love concealed carry laws,
they don't love open carry laws.
They don't love
everybody having a gun.
It makes their job a
lot more difficult.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So it seems like
community policing
is one of the best ways to
get the police more engaged
with the community, and
to get the community
to see the police as a
force that will help them,
as opposed to just arrest them,
or enforce the laws on them.
This is kind of a
question for both of you,
and for King County,
what's stopping us
right now from just rolling
out a larger community policing
effort?
BARRY FRIEDMAN: So
first, I just want
to draw a distinction,
which Deborah drew,
between community policing
and community engagement
because I think it's important.
So community policing,
as you identified,
is a way to get the
cops out of their cars,
and walking around, and meeting
people in the community.
And generally, we should favor
that as a method of policing.
Though we should
also be conscious
of unintended consequences,
because we always have them
around policing.
And so there was
some community that
had this idea that it would be
great if, on Friday afternoons,
the cops would just come up and
high-five all the kids coming
out of school.
A lot of parents
were like, whoa,
we just don't
really want the cops
around high-fiving anybody.
And you know, that's a
function of a loss of trust,
and a loss of legitimacy.
We were moving toward
a community policing
model in this country, and
then we had a war on drugs.
And then we had a war on terror.
And it's hard to have community
policing when you're at war.
And so Sue Rahr, who is the
former Sheriff of King County
and now runs a training
facility talks a lot
about the difference
between cops
being warriors and guardians.
But a lot of departments
are moving toward community
policing models.
The NYPD is moving pretty
quickly toward one.
We're doing some
work in Chicago,
and they're trying
to move themself
to set up that kind
of community policing.
So it's the right direction.
DEBORAH JACOBS: I
would just throw in,
one other thing is resource.
You ask what stops
it, is resources.
There are so many
differences in capacities
of police departments.
And you know, how many people?
Are they doing--
King County happens
to be an extremely
lean department.
That will give you an example
to compare it to Seattle.
In Seattle, they've done
amazing work on their crisis
intervention in terms of
people in behavioral crisis.
So if they get a call, for
example, with a suicidal,
possibly armed person,
they'll spend up to an hour--
first of all, they'll have
an officer there that's been
trained and certified in--
they call it CIT, people
in behavioral crisis.
And then they'll spend
up to an hour trying
to engage them from
outside, giving them
lots of time and space.
You all saw in Seattle
a few weeks ago,
downtown was shut down because
there was a knife-wielding man.
And there was a confrontation
with the police that took
two or three hours to resolve.
They were using, I think,
the greatest tool of all,
which is patience, you know?
Giving that time and space
to the community members
in order to engage.
But you have to
have the capacity,
you have to have the
physical resources.
In King County, the sheriff's
deputies right alone.
Seattle they ride in pairs.
And in King County, you could be
up to an hour from your backup.
So that also influences.
And also just the rural
nature of a lot of the land.
So I think one of the
challenges in coming up
with good solutions
to reform policing
is to make it scalable.
And so when--
I don't know, what department?
When Tukwila hears what
Seattle's doing, they're like,
ugh, you know, we can't do it.
So thinking in
those terms as well,
what's possible
within what you have.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have a
bunch of questions
that I was trying to select one.
I keep changing my
mind up back there.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So--
BARRY FRIEDMAN:
You can have two.
It's a special day today.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: All right, I'll
do two since I'm just going
to stand here and freak out.
DEBORAH JACOBS: It's Cinco
de Mayo, you can have five.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So-- and I start
really freaking out now.
So one of my question is, I
guess, more for Barry because I
guess you'll explain it.
Why, in terms of your
focus, you chose policing.
Because there are other
enforcement people--
I don't know what you call
those, that also affects
the life of the civilians.
Like, for example, the
DA, or the immigration.
So, yeah that's
my first question.
BARRY FRIEDMAN: So
I'm going to give you
a rather personal
answer to that question.
So I hit a point in my
career for various reasons
where I really wanted--
I felt I wasn't enough
publicly engaged
in what was it that I would do.
And when that happened and
I was thinking through that,
I was also writing this book.
And of course I didn't
reach the obvious conclusion
by adding two and two
together that policing
would be the thing to do.
And then Snowden happened,
and I realized that I--
that the ideas in
the book mattered
a lot in the real world, and
that I could maybe apply them.
And then as we
were working on how
to set up the policing
project, Ferguson happened.
And it's been kind of like being
shot out of a cannon since then
with the work that we do.
And by the way, I want to
follow Deborah's discussion
about what all of you can do.
Because in our work, there's
huge needs for technology.
So I-- that's the path I took
because it's what I knew.
But I think that many of
the same issues that I'm
raising about policing in
front end accountability
completely apply to prosecutors.
They may be more independent
than anybody else
in the system.
And so it's a perfectly
fair question,
but this problem feels
this big some days.
And so it's all I can
kind of grapple with.
Thank you.
You want another one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BARRY FRIEDMAN: Good.
AUDIENCE: So my
other question was,
how much partnership
and cooperation
you have with the
police department,
or the various policing people?
Because I see them.
There's-- one, there's
always this story about
that's the good cop and bad cop.
And a lot of people go to
the job because they do
feel that they--
becoming a police
or law enforcement,
they are doing things.
And so they won't to grow
up and get their job,
and become hated by everyone.
So how much
cooperation is there?
How is that?
BARRY FRIEDMAN: Yeah, so
that's a good question.
So the policing project, we
work with policing agencies all
the time, and with communities.
So depending upon
the community, we're
kind of in a different role.
In Cleveland, we're working
with the federal monitor doing
community engagement in terms
of getting the community to have
input into the monitoring plan.
They're under a consent
decree following
Tamir Rice to deal with
use of force issues.
In Camden, we're there
because the police chief
asked us to come in and help
him engage with his community,
and deal with some
of these issues.
We're setting up a--
you saw on the slide, a
advisory council in Tucson.
We're working with the
L.A. Police commission.
It's the only civilian-run
police department
in the country to ask the
question to the public, what
do we do about
body camera footage
after there's been an
officer-involved shooting?
And so we often feel like
we're operating in a minefield.
We talk a lot about
walking a very thin line.
I'm very careful
about the things
I say in public because
the public is there,
the community is there,
but also the police.
And it's easy to alienate
one or the other.
But the goal is to try
to bring them together.
And I try to--
Ana and I were
talking about this.
I try to think the best of
people in every situation,
and assume that they're
acting in good faith,
and are often in
just bad situations.
And I have found that if you--
it's slow, slow, painful work.
It is really remarkable
how hard some of it is.
But you get these
glimmers of sunlight
when people are communicating
with one another,
and progress is being made.
And the police realize they
can listen to the community,
and it's not
threatening to them.
And that the community
actually is supportive,
and has ideas for how to
do things differently.
And the community realizes that
the police are not just there
to terrorize them,
but actually are
folks who came to the job
originally thinking that they
would do something good.
And so that happens too
seldom, but when it happens,
I think it's pretty magical.
And that's the idea.
DEBORAH JACOBS:
If you don't mind,
I'll also throw in
two cents on that one.
Hands down, the
hardest part of my job
is trying to work
both collaboratively
and adversarialy with
the department I oversee.
I'm very fortunate because
our Sheriff, John Urquhart,
is very progressive.
He, for example, has
taken a strong stand
about not enforcing civil
immigration enforcement
for the federal government.
He also has been
great, progressive
on drug policy issues.
But we're-- as I described, we
kind of review what they do.
So it's like
[CAT FIGHTING NOISES] you know?
And you have to-- you want
to find your common areas,
and march those forward, and
also deal with the pain points.
And people in my field
get fired all the time.
I don't think I even
have any friends who
have worked in this field
who haven't been fired
from their jobs
eventually because you
have to be pro-community,
and collaborative
with law enforcement, as well.
So it's kind of--
it's a struggle,
and frankly, is calling on
the depths of my maturity,
to the extent there are any.
[LAUGHS]
BARRY FRIEDMAN:
You know, I just--
if you think about
it, in government--
and it's important
for what I want
to say about what the
tech community can offer,
the front end and the
back end of policing
should talk to one another, just
like everything else, right?
So I am party to a lot of
anguished conversations
with folks that are angry
that police officers have not
been held accountable, that
they've not been indicted.
And part of the reason
is because we are not
clear enough on the front
end about what we expect.
The standards are
very, very vague.
So you can have a very
effective back end
unless you've got a front end
that's got legitimacy to it,
and that tells people
what's expected of them.
And by the same token,
what Deborah does,
she's got exactly
the right model
going in the sense of,
if you're on the back end
and you see where
there are problems,
then that ought to inform
how you want to have
new policies on the front end.
And it all ought to work
that way, in a healthy way.
So even though it's adversarial
and also collaborative,
that's how we're
supposed to be in terms
of being self-critical about
what government's doing,
and then improving it.
It doesn't happen that way very
often, but that's the idea.
You going to ask a que-- yeah.
Or were you just
holding up the--the--[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I'm just
hanging out over here.
No.
So first, thanks
for coming today.
I really enjoyed
both of those talks.
So I was going to say, I have
a lot of friends that are cops.
And with everything that's
been happening recently,
we talk a lot, I guess,
about what they're doing,
and what the community
thinks about it.
And one thing that
I've found is,
they kind of think
that a lot of policies
that are there to protect
citizens are against them.
One specific example
that I can think of
is, in Seattle, you have to pull
someone over only for the thing
that you're pulling
them over for, which
is different from other places.
And that makes sense to me.
I feel like that's
really good policy.
But to them, it's like, if
we suspect a guy of some drug
offense, and then we
see that he's speeding,
we can't use that as a reason
to pull him over and look
for something else.
And it's sort of a--
to them, it's hurting
them in doing their job.
And so what I'm
wondering is, is there
anything being done
to sort of bridge
that gap where they don't
feel like the policies
are against them,
and they can see
the benefit for the community?
And then also, is the problem
the incentive structure?
Yeah.
BARRY FRIEDMAN: So that's
a terrific question.
We conduct debates
in this country
in an unbelievably
unhealthy way.
And it's often you're
pro-cop or anti-cop.
Or you're-- sometimes I think
it's like you're pro-safety
and security, or
you're pro-liberty.
And I always wonder,
you know, I'm both.
I tell people I have young kids.
I live near the
World Trade Center.
I want to be safe and secure.
I want my kids to
be safe and secure.
And I also want to live in a
society where we have liberty,
and we treat one
another respectfully.
And I hate that we divide the
world up in that other way,
and then think about
things that way.
So what the officers are talking
about is, it has become very--
it became very common
in the United States
to engage in what
was often referred
to as proactive policing.
That meant lots of stops--
lots of pedestrian stops,
lots of traffic stops.
And cops will tell you,
they can stop anybody.
You follow somebody for
just a little bit of time,
there's 1,000 things
that you could do wrong
in the vehicle code.
It's easy to pull people over.
And then they get
consent to search.
And I looked at data from L.A.
at one point one quarter--
I mean, one half of a year.
And 19,000 some-100 people
were asked to consent,
and three people didn't.
So you wonder how
voluntary that consent is.
Though you do also want to
meet those three people.
[LAUGHTER]
And you know, that's a decision
for us to make as a soci--
I mean, first of all, there
are constitutional problems.
It's not clear that you should
be pulling over a lot of people
with no cause.
The meaning of living in a
liberal democracy like we are
is that you have a
certain amount of liberty,
and that shouldn't happen.
But that's the exact
question, which
is that we don't
say, how do we want
to fight crime while we
talk about being worried
about crime.
We don't have a conversation
about how part of that.
And we all ought to be
in that conversation,
and we should include the
police in the conversation.
Everywhere we go,
everything we do,
we hold focus groups
with the officers,
line officers, the brass.
They should be part
of the conversation.
But I hate the
notion that they have
the ownership over
that question,
or feel that they have
the ownership over it.
Remarkable documents sitting
on my desk from the Fraternal
organization, the
union in Chicago,
the superintendent in Chicago
in the middle of all the uproar,
new use of force policy.
Sends it out to the public to--
they had a cool online program,
and everybody could kind of
add comments and edit.
And the Fraternal
organization was outraged.
And they sent out this
email that basically said--
I mean, they used this phrase,
the world's turned upside down.
The superintendent's taken
our use of force policy,
and asked the public
what they think.
And all I could think
was, how crazy is that?
Asking the people
that you're going
to use force on what the policy
should be for using force,
right?
I mean, it wouldn't
strike any of us as crazy.
And that's just
something that's broken,
and that's exactly the thing
that we're trying to fix.
How to fix it?
So this will be my
pitch to all of you
out there about-- so this front
end accountability is really
difficult because we don't
have any structures for doing
it the United States.
We're making it all
up all the time.
And when you're making
it up all the time,
there are a lot of questions
that tread into the world
in which you live, and where
all of you can be helpful.
So we are working often in
very marginalized communities.
And there are inadequate
ways to conduct
participatory democracy,
and to do it in a way
that people aren't having
to come to a meeting
when they don't have
time come to a meeting,
they got kids to take care of.
And we need to have a easy
way for people to have input.
And the platforms
aren't very good.
We want to know if
what we're doing works.
And to figure out what
you're doing works,
you need to do a
lot of surveying.
And the platforms for--
there aren't platforms that
allow police departments
to easily go in and get
into their geo-coded parts
of their community,
and say, how we doing?
How's the new policy
affecting people?
To test legitimacy,
to test trust,
so that we can see
over time whether we're
making any progress.
Just doesn't exist.
Huge data needs.
So one of the things
we're looking at
is, there are measures
of the impacts
of policing that
people just have never
thought about very much.
So we want to kind of go in
and ask in communities where
there's been this kind
of proactive policing,
are there effects
on public health?
What about education rates?
Drop out?
Obviously offending and arrests?
And so there are
lots of opportunities
to engage in this project.
I mean, I commend Deborah
for all the suggestions she
had locally, but
those same problems
are multiplied through 18,000
different policing agencies.
I don't know if you
want to add anything.
I just went on and
on there, sorry.
DEBORAH JACOBS:
I'll just throw in
that I think we confront the
same kind of problem that we
confront with other groups
that are essentially
segregated from one
another, and that
is that we don't
know each other,
and we don't come into
each other's territory--
whether it's black and
white, or cops and civilians,
or whatever it is.
And so I think it's incumbent
upon those of us who
care about those things
to take those steps,
and try to meet each
other where we are.
From my office specifically,
we administrate
an alternative
dispute resolution.
I would way rather
see a cop spend
an hour in the room with
a facilitator talking
to a person who had a
complaint against them
than get a five day
suspension because I think
it's worth that much more.
I kind of think we need a
truth and reconciliation--
I don't what that
looks like, but I
think there's enough damage
that really stems from slavery
in particular that
we have more dialogue
to conduct before we're
going to be able to meet.
But someone like
you is invaluable.
You know some of these
people, but you also
have outside perspectives.
You can take your
bubble and their bubble,
and make a bubble bath.
[LAUGHTER]
BARRY FRIEDMAN: I love that.
I'm going to steal that.
DEBORAH JACOBS: No, you can't.
[LAUGHTER]
BARRY FRIEDMAN: It may not work
as well if I do the bubble bath
thing, but yeah.
AUDIENCE: So all this talk--
first, the great talk,
by the way.
Thanks for both of
you for coming--
to both of you for coming.
So all this talk
is about expanding
the oversight of the police
over the law enforcement.
And one of my--
the concerns I have
is that there's
no equal oversight over the
citizens in terms of organized
crime, for instance.
In other words,
we're restricting,
we are tying the
hands of the police,
but we are opening the hands
of the organized crime.
And what are your thoughts about
expanding the oversight one
way or another over
suspected criminals?
So maybe required that the
information, where they go,
is just as public as a
policeman, or anything
like that so that we can kind
of counter to the other trend,
that actually, as we
weaken the police--
and I've seen that
in other societies.
The police weakens, and the
organized crime strengthens.
So--
BARRY FRIEDMAN: So
that's a hard question.
It's particularly
difficult in part
because we don't
empirically know
whether we're empowering
criminals and limiting
the police, and where the
optimal level of enforcement
is.
I mean, you're exactly right--
there's some optimal level
of enforcement, right?
The law and economics
folks around me would say,
we just have to figure out the
optimal level of enforcement.
By the way, I just
want to say, I'm
not sure I want to
limit the police more.
I want to change the nature
of what we call oversight.
In fact, I don't like
the word oversight
for a lot of what
we do, I mean, you
know Deborah does oversight,
but on the front end,
I don't think of
it as oversight.
I think of it as
collaborating on figuring out
what the rules should be for
exactly what you're asking.
The other thing is,
technology has actually
addressed some of that problem.
So this is the question
you were going to plant,
and I'm now going to
relieve you of planting it
[LAUGHTER]
But so the-- guess we're
not supposed to let
people know that, either.
So the policing's
changed dramatically
in the last 30 years.
And I don't think
anybody noticed it,
just like technology
swept over all of us,
and we just kind of
adapted, but didn't--
then you have your whoa moment.
So policing used to be
all about suspicion,
or a lot about suspicion,
which was that you knew--
you had a reason to
think that somebody
was doing something wrong,
or had done something wrong.
And the Constitution was written
to focus on suspicion that way.
So we think about
probable cause, right?
Why is the government after you?
Because we have enough facts,
probable cause, to think
you've done something wrong.
Enough to justify getting
a warrant to search you.
And it was a very
suspicion-based model.
But if you think about the
way that policing looks today,
it's very different.
It's a deterrent-based
model, which
is that we're going to conduct
sufficient surveillance
over all of society that
we've got an eye on you.
And you know we
have an eye on you.
And hopefully-- you especially.
We're going to behave, right?
[LAUGHTER]
And so we're all going
to pay attention.
And so we're going to collect
everybody's telephone metadata.
And it's not just being
used for national security.
That information can
be queried by the FBI.
It's a real problem in the law.
We're going to have
airport security,
and we're just going
to get everybody
to march through it, right?
There's no cause to think
anybody's got a weapon, we just
we spent a ton of
money on the theory
that we're going to keep people
from showing up with weapons
in the first place.
And so we actually have a ton
of surveillance right now.
I mean, one of the big questions
is location-tracking, right?
We're all telling the police
where we are with our phones
at every moment.
And we have inadequate
legal controls
on getting that information.
So I'm not sure where
the balance is, and I
don't think any of us knows.
Because we don't tend
to think about things
in this world in any kind of
scientific, careful, thoughtful
way.
We just have a lot
of public rhetoric.
And I think that's a shame,
because I want us to be free,
and I want us to be safe.
And I published a piece
in the Outlook section
of the Washington Post
a few weeks ago that--
just to ask the question,
we spent $100 billion a year
on public safety, ought
we to know what works?
So I'm with you,
I want to be safe.
But I want to have a better
understanding of, actually,
where we are with that.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Oh, thank you.
Thank you for coming.
So my question is about--
you started your lecture
with a bunch of examples
where police clearly
misbehaved, or we
would call it bad policing,
and extreme examples.
What's the mental model that
you have about those cases?
Few bad apples?
Few bad districts?
BARRY FRIEDMAN: Yeah, no.
No.
AUDIENCE: Is it most of
the districts are bad?
What's the distribution, there?
BARRY FRIEDMAN: It's bad policy.
It's bad policy.
So-- and it's suboptimal policy.
So that's the point.
So we-- a lot of the problems
that I showed at the beginning,
I can walk you back
through and show you
how a more sensible policy
would have avoided that problem.
And if you thought that some
of those were problems--
I mean, just think
about the amount
of time and loss of human
dignity and discomfort
that's associated with forcibly
catheterizing somebody, right?
So I don't know if
we ever want to do.
And I'm not sure
that we ever want
to do it for the crime of
driving under the influence.
And if you were going to get
me to thinking we should ever
do it, we maybe should
do it if there's
a tragic accident, right?
But that's heavy-handed
police behavior,
and it's taking a cop
off of their patrol
where they'd be, maybe, missing
something far more serious,
right?
And so the police
shootings, every one
of which is an
extraordinary tragedy--
and I just want to
point something out
to you, which is that we
view the people who were shot
and their families as the
center of that tragedy, which
is exactly right.
But we often don't think
about the fact that--
and cops will tell you
this, that the cop who shot
somebody's life is destroyed.
And sometimes it's
justified, but their life's
still completely turned
upside down by having done it.
We don't want those
things to happen.
And so instead of just focusing
on who we're going to punish,
we should be asking the
question, how are we going
to avoid it in the first place?
It's a suboptimal policy, right?
And so-- I mean, that's
what I'm all about,
is data and optimization.
And that isn't how we've
approached policing.
It's not how we've approached
technology in policing.
I mean, Deborah was
talking about this.
What happens is, what-agency's
got a new gadget,
so then the next
agency wants it.
And they're not
thinking, do I already
have something that does that?
Am I thinking about how
the data is getting--
what the cost of storing
the data is going to be,
how I'm going to use the data?
So it's exactly
the right question.
And my soapbox, I'm
sorry, is that I
think that we should stop
always looking on the back end,
and looking for blame when
things go wrong, and say,
let's optimize policy
so they don't go wrong.
And we're actually
getting things right.
AUDIENCE: I get that argument.
My question is a little
bit more specific.
When I walk into average
department in the country,
would I observe--
what's the extent
I would see it?
Are there really
few bad departments?
Most of them are?
I'm using term
bad loosely, here.
BARRY FRIEDMAN: Yeah, I get it.
What's that distribution?
Are we trying to fix
few localized problems,
or is it universally
you pretty much
have to fix the whole system?
What's the--
DEBORAH JACOBS: I'm going to
answer a little bit similarly--
AUDIENCE: And it's subjective,
I understand very--
DEBORAH JACOBS: Yeah.
So one thing I would
say is, I don't
think there are bad apples, I
think there are bad orchards.
And what makes up the orchard
are some of the things
that Barry mentioned--
what kind of policies
are in place?
What kind of
training is in place?
And all those things contribute
to the ultimate thing,
which is the culture.
What is the culture
of the department?
And so for the most part, I
think that police departments
that have not had the benefit of
the sunlight shining upon them,
whether through litigation,
the DOJ, civilian oversight,
whatever it might be--
I think most of them
are problematic.
Not because they've done
something bad already,
but because they don't have the
policies and training in place
to make sure it doesn't happen.
And when a shooting
happens, they'll
land in-- so one of the issues
that [? Yves ?] and I just
talked about a little
earlier, on October 21, 2016,
a woman was killed by King
County sheriff's deputies
on the Muckleshoot
Indian Reservation.
They were-- it was
a wellness call.
She was suicidal, and they were
coming in response to that.
And things went terribly wrong.
There was going to be
an inquest in Kent.
It starts May 22.
And what they're going to do--
the purpose of an inquest,
which is used very
few jurisdictions,
but King County is one of
them, is to get the truth out
under oath.
What happened?
But citizens find that
process very dissatisfying
because they get out what
happened, and then what next?
But as they look
at that, they're
going to look--
was it justifiable?
But the lens we need to
have is, was it preventable?
And so when I look at a
department, is it good,
is it bad?
What policies and
training do they
have in place to prevent the
most common kinds of tragedies?
And I would posit-- and I
don't have the numbers on this,
but that the mental health or
behavioral health crises stuff
is the key place where we
need to be focusing resources.
Because that is such a breadth
of what they deal with.
Also related to some
comments you made,
I want to say that we as
a society need to decide--
do we want police to
enforce minor things?
Do we want them to stop Michael
Brown for crossing-- walking
down the middle of the street?
Sandra Bland for her
broken taillight?
Eric Garner for doing
whatever he was doing,
hanging out on the streets?
My answer is no.
I think we have
over-enforcement.
But then what happens to
those quality of life things?
How do we address those?
Because we do care
about them, we all do.
We have to come up
with other systems.
And we can't keep
recruiting people
to be armed cops jumping
out of helicopters when
actually they're social
workers, that's what the job is.
So rethinking the
job description
seems critically
important to me.
And then hiring on that basis,
and having the community
understand that what
you don't want enforced,
we're going to have to
find another answer for,
whether it's something
you lobby for in Olympia,
or something that you
implement as a community.
But a lot of that rests with us.
We've put these
problems at their feet,
and they're not trained or
equipped to deal with them.
BARRY FRIEDMAN: I'm going to
give you just a slightly more
precise answer
because I appreciate
the precision of the question.
So it's kind of remarkable.
So the NYPD has about
35,000 officers.
There are plenty of departments
that have one or two officers.
I think the median in
the country of the 18,000
departments is 10 officers.
So it's quite a distribution.
What surprises you when
you get into policing
is how it's kind of like
you're walking into the past,
and how things
haven't moved along.
And so again, I don't
think they're bad.
They're not modernized.
There's been nothing
to cause modernization.
And to the contrary,
what happens is,
we'll starve departments
for cash sometimes,
or it's just used in bad ways.
And here's another thing, this
is a money-making thing here
at Google.
So there's a lot of talk
about transparency and data,
and we don't have
data on policing.
So it's hard to have data
on 18,000 separate entities.
That's tough to do.
But one of the reason--
so the story we
tell is-- well, we
don't have data
because the police
don't want to give it up.
I tell that story in the
first few pages of my book.
I believe that to be true.
But a lot of it is just
an embarrassment of data
in the sense of, they don't--
we decided that we
were curious about stop
data, demographic stop data.
And where would we get it?
Well, there are some
departments under court order,
so we'll just call them up
and see if they'll share it,
or they're supposed to share it.
We literally called
up some departments,
and they said, yeah,
we'll get it to you.
What's your fax number?
And they're ready to fax over
their sheet of their figures.
And so I actually
think that we'd
have so much more policing data
if we had the tools developed
to collect the data.
And I think there's a real
financial opportunity here,
which is that there are
18,000 departments--
and I think they would use
many similar platforms,
and then we would
have unified data.
But it's really a--
I mean, there are
some bad apples,
but that's not the right story.
It's just where
modernization didn't happen.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BARRY FRIEDMAN: Thank you.
You want to stop us now.
Stop us before we kill again.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Thank you
so much for coming.
BARRY FRIEDMAN: Thank
you guys, really.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank
you.